[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con israel tiene
una de las campañas de vacunación contra
el coi 19 más avanzadas del mundo tanto
así que hace más de una semana las
autoridades retiraron el uso obligatorio
de la mascarilla en lugares abiertos
ahora se espera que empiecen a vacunar a
menores de entre 12 y 15 años para
ampliar este tema nos acompaña el doctor
simpson hermana de la asociación médica
de israel gracias por estar con nosotros
las inoculaciones en este país se llevan
a cabo con la vacuna de facer y el
laboratorio indicó en marzo pasado que
el fármaco sería 100% efectivo en
jóvenes de 12 a 15 años pero porque
israel está esperando la autorización de
la administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu
señorita todo el tiempo se hizo así
desde el inicio nosotros esperamos
obtener el término ver qué es lo que
hace la gente y cuando ellos aceptaron
nosotros producen lo aceptamos
es lógico hay que tener una información
clara ellos tienen la información creada
y por esa razón nosotros esperamos que
además los padres quieren escuchar eso
no es una cuestión de un decir ok eso
damon walk una
doctor hermano se estima que en israel
el 81% de la población es mayor de 16
años y ya todas estas personas han
recibido dos dosis de la vacuna de facer
en principio se dijo que el coi 19 ha
afectado mayormente a adultos pero que
tan afectados se han visto en los
jóvenes en israel que tan importante es
vacunar a adolescentes y a niños para
alcanzar la inmunidad de rebaño
hemos visto en los últimos tiempos que
los jóvenes son los que son más
afectados el 40% de los internos legales
eran jóvenes
no eran los anuncios que estábamos todos
vacunarnos ya que cuando los jóvenes
empezaron aumentando
expuestos más hemos visto que en una
cantidad abrumadora de gente joven
intentarlo
y por eso no hay duda en nosotros
creemos que hay que vacunarse no
interesa con qué vacuna
la faisán en la moderna la azteca
la china cualquiera de ellas sin vacuna
es peor que como esta que recibir una
vacuna no la mejor del mundo
doctor el ministerio de salud de israel
anunció que estaba estudiando una
supuesta relación causal entre casos de
inflamación del músculo cardíaco en
jóvenes y la vacuna de facer que se sabe
hasta el momento
y ese es un problema que no hay duda que
hay que estudiarlo pero creemos que fue
más
jóvenes que tenían un problema de
colitis que no un producto de la vacuna
así es lo que pensamos pero hay que
seguir esperando hay que seguir
estudiando la cantidad de gente que ha
sido vacunado todavía no ha llegado a
las cifras que podamos tomar tener
información más exacta como hemos tenido
de otras cosas
no sólo sabemos que una cosa es la
vacuna la vacunación en los jóvenes al
principio con una dosis es una cosa pero
si completan las dos dosis es distinto y
es posible que las miocarditis
desaparecieron fueron en gente que
estuvieron con una sola dosis
doctor la velocidad en la campaña de
vacunación hace pensar que no tomaría
tanto tiempo vacunar al 100 por ciento
de la población del país una vez que
haya todas las autorizaciones de las
autoridades necesarias esta población es
de más de 9 millones de personas pero el
primer ministro anunció que comprara 16
millones más de vacunas para otra ronda
de inyecciones en 6 meses a qué se debe
esta decisión
si ustedes quieren a los políticos y sin
opuestos reunieron este dolor y nosotros
todavía no tenemos una decisión y hay
que dar una una tercera dosis posible
porque esperan esperar los resultados no
se puede embargar y decir si ya
compramos vacuna
es una cuestión de idiosincrasia de las
personas
nosotros los que germán disculpe no se
nos acaba el tiempo de discusión pero
muchas gracias por toda la información y
el análisis que nos compartió a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía que en france 24
[Música]